and
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to our
videos about conservation today I
'm going to be telling you about
preventive conservation which is
preventive conservation is what we
do in the museum to take care of the
specimens and objects that we have
for researchers  you can
use them in the future and so that all of
you can enjoy them when you
come to visit the museum and what we do
when we do preventive conservation
we look at the 10 agents of
deterioration I am not going to tell you about
the 10 but I am going to tell you
About some, for example, the light that
illuminates us all the time or the sun and all
that can be very problematic for
collections, so we
look at visible light and ultraviolet light
when we go to the beach or when
we are exposed to the sun.  we
can get red after
being exposed to the sun for a while but the
special ones obviously do not stay with
red skin and what can happen to them is
that they can start to whiten they can
start to have color problems and
they change the colors, for example, of
the feathers or the colors in the fabrics and
all those things, so
we use some things in preventive conservation, such
as a
device that is here that is  calls the
sec and it looks like an old cell phone but it's not
an old cell phone what we do
is monitor with these two monitors
that are here the light for example the
visible light there is telling us that
we have 621 looks which for a
laboratory is fine because  it helps us to
see what we are doing and
working with the specimens and
we can also monitor the ultraviolet light the
ultraviolet light is less than
60 which is fantastic if we
have more than 75 it is a problem for
the specimens so the values  that
we have now mean that these
specimens can be here in the
laboratory for a long time and do not have
any problems other things that we have
to  take care of are the temperature and the
humidity that we can also measure with
this fantastic little device if I
show them for example the humidity is
less than 55 percent and the
temperature is about 71 paren
height then these two values
so good values for specimens
and they make it possible for us to
be with them in the laboratory for a
long time if we have very high temperatures and
very high humidity also what
happens is that things start to degrade
very quickly so in the museum
we always try to have temperatures and
humidity not only not that  they are not
high but there cannot be
fluctuations either because if there are
fluctuations it is when we begin to
have problems and another thing that
I am also going to show you is that we
have to clean the specimens
so when you have vacuum cleaners in your house you
have more or
less these  elements to use in the
vacuum cleaners but we in the museum
have others that I am going to  show that they
are very adorable
look at the difference in size between the
brushes that we use in our homes and
those that we use in
museum conservation then these brushes are
great because they are super delicate and do not
affect any of the specimens
when we are using the vacuum cleaner
no  I am going to turn on the vacuum cleaner now
because they make a lot of noise, but I am going
to show you how we can also
clean the specimens with other
elements, such as these little
sponges that are very similar to the
makeup sponges that are bought
in pharmacies and that we have here  a
horse skull that was on display in the
hall of mammals until very recently
in the museum and now it's in the
lab with me so I'm going
to show you first of course to
make the gloves before touching any
specimen
and I'm going to  show more or less how
we do to clean
so I end up in this area that has a
lot of dust I'm going to  come with this little
sponge and I'm going to start slowly look at
the difference after giving
the sponge a super soft touch look at this
this is not very happy but well this is
the process we have to do in
conservation which is very very slowly and
very calm so that
none of the specimens are damaged so here's
a demonstration of what we
can do to take care of the
specimens in the museum whether it's with the
temperature with the humidity with the light
with the dust and a lot of other things that
we also do to take care of  the
specimens do not miss the
next videos that we are going to have, which
are cleaning and repairing feathers in
embalmed birds and also bone,
thank you very much see you later
[Music]